in the Quran Allah is absolutely
obsessed with making sure everyone knows
he's only one God and yet over and over
again in the Quran Allah refers to
himself using plural pronouns we our us
why would Allah use we our and us when
he has no partner why would Allah
confuse his followers and undermine
toed in this video we'll go through some
examples of Allah's preferred pronouns
in the Quan then we'll read a few
comments about the confusion Allah has
caused by misnumber himself then we'll
hear from Muslim experts including
zachar Nik Numan alian and shik Assam
al-hakim who explain why Allah
identifies as plural finally we'll see
how Allah's transition from singular to
plural points us to the Trinity let's
get this plural parade started Surah 50:
and verily we created the heavens and
the Earth and all that is between them
in six days and not of weariness touched
us we created the heavens and the Earth
not of weariness touched us plural days
plural allahs Surah 2 ver 23 and if you
are in doubt as to that which we have
revealed to our servant then produce a
chapter like it and call on your
Witnesses besides Allah if you are
truthful if you are in doubt as to that
which we have revealed to our servant
here Allah refers to himself in the
plural as he claims that no one can
write anything as wonderful as a chapter
of the
Quran Surah 2 ver 106 whatever
Communications we abgate or cause to be
forgotten we bring one better than it or
like it do you not know that Allah has
power over all things whatever
Communications we abgate we bring one
better than it or like it Allah uses
plural pronouns as he points out that
whenever he abreg hates or cancels a
verse of his perfect Eternal speech he
replaces that verse of his perfect
Eternal speech with something better
than it or like it Surah
4:56 those who reject our signs we shall
soon cast Into the Fire as often as
their Skins are roasted through we shall
change them for fresh skins that they
may taste the penalty for God is exalted
in power wise those who reject our signs
we shall soon cast Into the Fire as
often as their Skins are roasted through
we shall change them for fresh
skins that's a Stern warning to anyone
who has a problem with Allah's preferred
pronouns in the Quran Quan Surah 10:
94 but if you Muhammad are in doubt as
to what we have revealed to you ask
those who read the book before you
certainly the truth has come to you from
your lord therefore you should not be of
the
disputers if you are in doubt as to what
we have revealed to you Muhammad was
having doubts about whether his
Revelations were really coming from God
if you've read Muhammad's earliest
biography you know that his first
impression of his Revelations was that
they were demonic he had to be talked
out of this view by his wife and her
cousin who weren't in the cave with him
and who had no clue what possessed him
but his doubts occasionally resurfaced
and Allah used plural pronouns when he
told Muhammad to go to the people of the
book Jews and Christians to make sure
his Revelations lined up with our
Revelations spoiler alert they don't so
Muhammad failed the test and now his
followers are forced to say that our
book has been corrupted Surah
66:2 and Mary daughter of Imran who
guarded her private parts and we
breathed therein of our spirit and she
verified the words of her Lord and his
books and was of The Devout we breathed
therein of our spirit Spirit many
Muslims insist that the spirit of Allah
here is the Angel Gabriel which would
mean that Allah uses plural pronouns as
he describes breathing the angel Gabriel
into Mary's private
parts Allah uses this plural language we
our us like a beating drum in the Quran
and this raises an obvious question
which people ask me whenever I quote any
of these verses if Allah is trying so
hard to convince his listeners and
readers that he's a Unitarian deity why
does he repeatedly identify as plural by
using pronouns like we our and us let me
give you a few examples from the comment
section of my last video where I quoted
the Quran inquiring minds want to know
we created you who is the we why does
the Quran when speaking of Allah's
actions always refer to him as we do
Muslims pick up on the we in the verse
about how we put the human body together
time stamp 4:30 who is the we in the
Quran verse being quoted who is the we
poetic but not truth who is we why Allah
said we made isn't just one Creator or
they have a trinity concept as well we
created you from dust who is we in the
Quran does anyone ever find it weird the
Quran always uses we that we have sent
down so who are we Muslims if Allah has
no Partners or didn't copy from the
Bible then who is the wi how do you not
realize that Muhammad copied from the
Bible if he didn't then how does he get
we sent it
down so much confusion caused by Allah's
preferred pronouns why does he use them
sadly he never explains in his perfectly
clear book that always confuses everyone
who reads it but his followers are here
to help with this confusion and they
want us to know that Allah is using the
plural of majesty the plural of respect
the Royal we to demonstrate his
greatness and his glorious
nature brother V in Arabic the two types
one is V for plural one is Royal plural
some places uses I some places uses V
the V in Arabic does not indicate
plurality it means Royal plural why is
we used for Allah in the Quran that's
the question in the Quran you will
find different kinds of pronouns used
for Allah the only time he uses the
plural is in which person first person
and in first person you find Anna and
you
find and I and weu is used when Allah
speaks in the role of a
king in the role of majesty Allah uses
plural form to indicate his greatness
when Allah subhana tala uses the wordu
for himself referring to himself in the
Glorious Quran it is not the plural of
number but it is a royal plural or
plural of respect in Arabic language and
also in other languages such a pronoun
can be used when an individual is
glorifying himself
they use the pronoun we as a form of
glorification and this is well known in
Arabic and Allah definitely is the most
worthy of such glorification Allah knows
best so when Allah uses the pronouns we
our and us it's because he's a fan of
the plural of majesty what's the plural
of majesty the plural of majesty is the
use of plural pronouns to refer to a
singular subject or person in order to
assert the majesty and greatness and
glory of the subject or person keep in
mind that Allah uses the plural of
majesty from all eternity the Quran is
supposedly Allah's Eternal speech so
from all eternity Allah has been
referring to himself as plural even
though he's not in order to declare and
demonstrate his majesty and
greatness but notice the underlying
assumption here the underlying
Assumption of the plural of majesty is
that it's greater and more Majestic to
be plural it's greater and more Majestic
to be a we than to be an i if Allah uses
plural pronouns to declare and
demonstrate his majesty then being
plural is somehow more Majestic than
being
singular nevertheless the Quran
regularly affirms at least in principle
that monotheism is superior to
polytheism the Quran condemns polytheism
monotheism is the only acceptable the
ology in
Islam now if monotheism is the only
acceptable Theology and yet being plural
is greater and more Majestic than being
singular what can we
conclude we can conclude that according
to Allah himself in his eternal speech
the greatest most majestic deity would
be a deity that is monotheistic and yet
somehow plural according to Allah
himself in his eternal speech the
greatest most majestic deity would be
not an absolute Unity but some sort of
compound Unity according to Allah
himself in his eternal speech the
greatest most majestic deity would not
be Unitarian but dare I say
trinitarian according to Islam then the
Unitarian god of the Quran just isn't as
great or Majestic as the Triune god of
the Bible I couldn't agree more Muslims
and I finally have something that we can
agree on completely the Triune God of
the Bible is greater and more Majestic
than the wannabe plural god of the Quran
the god of the Bible can refer to
himself using plural pronouns and really
mean it because he exists eternally as
Father Son and Holy Spirit the less
Majestic god of the Quran can refer to
himself using plural pronouns but he
can't really mean it because even though
he admires plurality and regards it as
more Majestic than Singularity he
remains forever lonely in his total
isolation
and yet our Muslim friends criticize and
even mock the Trinity even though the
Trinity is according to the Quran itself
a greater and more Majestic concept of
God than Ted the god of the Bible can
use plural pronouns and mean it the god
of the Quran can only identify as plural
he's trans
plural does that mean we have to affirm
Allah's preferred
pronouns not at all
Allah orders Christians to say not
three hey Allah of the Quran say not we
[Music]